la 12e circonscription des yvelines fief
du républicain david douillet pourrait
bien basculer du côté de la république
en marche
florence granger investi par le
mouvement des manuels macron a obtenu 41
0 2% des suffrages exprimés contre 26
93% pour le député sortant
un résultat qui prouve bien la demande
de renouvellement de la classe politique
selon la candidate marcheuse elle même
issue de la société civile c'est sa
première élection comme au national
on a une comment dire une volonté de
changement qui s'est traduite de la part
des électrices et des électeurs
on voit qu'il ya quand même une volonté
de renouvellement des visages les usages
comment comme on l'a déjà dit il ya
maintenant quand on se dit qu'on reste
toujours prudent parce que ce n'est que
le premier tour des élections parce que
on a comment dire des résultats qui font
bien évidemment qui font pas confirmé un
résultat à confirmer surtout compte tenu
du faible taux de participation dans
cette circonscription comme dans le
reste de la france seulement un électeur
sur deux s'est déplacé aux urnes un taux
d'abstention pointé du doigt par
l'ensemble des parties notamment france
insoumise son candidat antoine barreau
est arrivé troisième avec presque 10 %
des voix il se dit déçu de ne pas avoir
mobilisé les électeurs
cela étant maintenant vous faut vraiment
qu'il ya une vraie après la france un
soul c'est une vraie force d'opposition
de gauche je comprends pas d'ailleurs
que dans certaines circonscriptions la
hausse à jour est difficile un
regroupement qui aurait peut-être pu
profiter au parti socialiste en 2012 il
avait récolté 34 % des voix au premier
tour
cette année il se hisse derrière le
front national
avec 5,7 pour cent les élections
législatives depuis 15 ans depuis 2002
ne sont qu'un reflet
des élections présidentielles donc je
savais très bien que je ne pourrai pas
gagner
néanmoins ce qui m'intéressait justement
c'est que vive la démocratie
un français une française sur deux en
âge de voter ne va pas voter et en fait
c'est le vrai problème pour notre
démocratie
selon les prévisions la république en
marche et le modem arriverait en tête
dans toutes les circonscriptions du
département
les différents candidats s'accordent sur
l'importance de la mobilisation pour le
second tour il invite les électeurs à se
manifester
même pour voter blanc malgré nos
sollicitations ce lundi david douillet
n'a pas donné suite à nos demandes
d'interview